[Musique]
on est amis premiers mois que ça
changera absolument rien paillotes
qu'est ce qui pourrait changer j'ai pris
des décrets 15 et ça au cas où ce soit
ça
oh oh je sais pas quoi faire
victoria des gens vous pourrez son sens
quoi de lui
moi je trouve ça génial que tu es un
plan sur cinq ans - dragon au plan sur
cinq ans
si on se mariait titre les couples et
cergy j'ai beaucoup réfléchi depuis hier
soir y pense depuis hier n'en croyais
que c'était plus dur que ça requiert une
réflexion
qui a toujours un moment dans la vie où
l'on doit se demander quelles sont vos
priorités
[Musique]
j'étais loin de me douter que vous aviez
une relation oui on est surtout ami
essentiellement à part une journée enfin
c'était une nuit même pas juste une demi
heure puis toi